spring in charles barkley NBA on tnt
hall-of-famer Charles before I get to
the bigger topic here I do want to ask
you about the Carmelo Anthony trade and
what does that mean for not only the
Knicks moving forward we'll get to the
other stuff but I wanted to get the
basketball stuff out of the way first of
all good morning thanks for joining us
no problem thank you for having me I
thought it was a good trade for the
Knicks I'm a big cancer fan so now that
they can start their rebuild in earnest
I don't know how to st. gonna work in
Oklahoma City I think that there's got
to be so much noise only because if it
Russell doesn't sign has extension soon
I think people going to assume he's
gonna leave and I think people are
already assuming that Paul George is
gonna leave so they go they're gonna be
having the answer that all season long
that's just from a duchess from on the
outside looking in it's for how good a
team maker be I'm not sure they don't
think they can beat the Warriors and I'm
not sure they can be the Rockets well I
also looked at this I wanted to see what
the impact would be with Melo going to
Oklahoma City with Las Vegas their title
odds went from 20 to 1 to 16 to 1 but
also their projected win total only went
up 1 from 51 and a half to 52 and a half
I don't know if you can teach him to be
different at this age Chris Bosh was
able to do this Kevin Love was able to
do this I don't know if Melo can do what
those guys did because they also did
other things to help their team's win
championships listen I don't think
Oklahoma they gonna be fascinating to
watch but you know I don't come out with
a terrific offensive player and I don't
think that's going to change I don't
think he's gonna get great or he's gonna
become a great rebounder and a great
defender to be honest with you but he's
a good player you don't obviously own
the downside of his career but it was a
good trade for the Knicks a guys like I
say they got two good players
and now they can look start going
forward now yeah they get rid of Melos
salary which is the biggest thing I
think they wanted to do also d-wade is
out in Chicago and you look at the
options does he go back to Miami for a
homecoming
does he reunite with LeBron maybe the
San Antonio Spurs what do you think is
that where do you thinks the best place
for d-wade now well I think he's got to
go to Miami you know I do I think just
Miami probably the best fit for him you
can go back there and get a hero's
welcome he's not going out west no he
did he don't want that fight you know
what the West is loaded you don't want
that every night and listen Cleveland
they deal I'm not sure how much here I
help Cleveland but you're part of go to
Miami but that's just a great homecoming
talking to Charles Barkley the Hall of
Famer Turner Sports NBA analyst if you
were on the Golden State Warriors and
you had to vote how would you weigh in
on wanting to go to the White House or
not well I think anytime you get an
opportunity to go to the White House
it's an honor and a privilege don't care
who the president is I think you should
go and if you have some disagreements I
think how many times you don't get an
opportunity to sit down with the
president discuss some issues with him I
mean not going it's over with it just
get his back these gas bags on TV and
radio so I'm gonna talk about he's not
gonna go now so it's over with I mean
I'm in a chant he they would have had a
chance to sit down with the president
United States and say some things now
that's not gonna happen
now these idiots on TV and radios on
talked about it but it and like that's
where we're at now people just talking
okay what do you how do we move this
forward well that's important you know
Dan you see us I'm early and it always
annoys me when people said then I've
never voted Republican a day in my life
I'm a Democrat I didn't just for the
record Democrats aren't doing anything
black people either just for the record
okay well then I apologize I thought
we'd talked about you talking about
being a Republican before on this show
no no my mother's asked me was we a
Republican Democrat and she said only
rich people Republican I said we do know
we're rich people assume that I said
that but okay I do want to make that
clear okay
I've always voted Democratic but they're
not doing anything fuzzy so just I want
to make that clear okay they're not
doing anything for us either that to me
as to what the big question is we have
spent so much time you know the media
has hijacked this entire I said there's
like three weeks ago the media has
totally hijacked this conversation about
who's milling who's not nailing who's
holding their fists up I forgot what why
these guys are doing it and until the
players realized listen we got a lot of
power we got to use that power in a
positive way don't let the media have us
call it Argan and yelling and screaming
we got a lot of power and we can really
go into ourselves
and with a number one you can get help
from these teams now could they feel
pressure to we can go into some of these
communities and do a lot of positive
stuff don't worry about what the
president says don't worry about what
the politicians doing but they're not
doing anything but the players they got
so much money now we've got so much
influence we need to take a progressive
approach and go in these communities
ourselves and try to make a difference
what do you think of these shows of if
you want to see a protest or of unity or
support with what the players are doing
is it the right way to go about this
well I don't tell people how to protest
and not protest you do what you want to
I would stand for the national anthem
personally but I don't ever tell anybody
how to protest and especially if they're
peaceful if they're peaceful that's the
right way to go but listen he's got now
they got the platform they got to use it
because we're gonna spend all our
wasting our time
that's what the players got to be
smarter they
understand the media is not our friends
we're gonna spend all our time that
today and probably for the rest of the
week talking about kneeling or being
unpatriotic to the flag desktop is not
it that's not the thing what are we
protesting for we got to realize that we
don't let the media make all this money
cuz they on TV or radio 24/7 talking
about who's kneeling and people call
them in an argument for four hours out
of time but what are they arguing about
that's the most important thing yeah
trying to figure this out what the owner
showing their support the players as we
move it forward how the fans react to
this if the president follows up with
something on this doesn't feel like it's
going away anytime soon Charles well
it's not gonna go away soon because
that's people love this stuff this is
what drives the 24-hour news cycle this
is my point about the players got to say
what can what can we do collectively
let's don't worry about the president
those just don't worry about the media
what can I can we do individually and
like I say we got so much money and so
much power now we've got these these
first of all these owners got to stick
with the players and these guys are all
billionaire they can't piss their
players off so they can go to the owners
and say let's go into these communities
and do some of these things but instead
of wasting time about kneeling and who's
protesting don't lose the message they
got a lot of power now they got to use
it they've got to be tweeting they got
to use their power what would you say to
President Trump well you know it's
interesting that somebody with that much
power it's been in his time on Twitter
we got the situation I mean think about
it there we got three natural disasters
in this country right now we got Texas
we got Florida we got Puerto Rico and
he's spending his time worrying about
who's kneeling on the sidelines and like
I say I was embarrassed because you know
I got all those ignorant rednecks down
in Alabama who went crazy when he said
it I mean what is all the bad stuff
always happen with idiots and Alabama I
mean it pisses me off I mean I
understand I'm from the south and I know
the South is always gonna be full of a
bunch of redneck but it's still
frustrating every time times something
really stupid and bad happens it happens
down south and unfortunately it's in my
state now and that sucks always good to
talk to you Charles we appreciate your
time all right my brother y'all take
care keep up the great work man Charles
Barkley Democrat and hall-of-famer the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience